[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
is there um in your experience any
advantage of wearing the headphones if
it's just us in here yeah i mean it's
like more focusing and uh i'll try it
out sounds cool to hear your voice
i've never done the headphones
that's what joe rogan does yeah oh this
is weird yeah well this is what it's
gonna sound like to the people listening
that's true
okay i like it this is strange
i'm gonna probably comment on this a few
times in the beginning i guess we'll
just get started today
my guest today uh you all know him from
kill tony just got done opening for joe
rogan uh hans kim hey what's up guys
good to be here great to have you here
thank you for uh making time for me uh
on this trip
uh this business park is kind of kind of
a crazy thing yeah yeah they don't
advertise it no and i went into because
i couldn't find this building i went
into three different stores around here
thinking that they'd all know where each
other are none of them have heard of
this or knew where it was
um so i was really just running around
very sweaty
um first time wearing headphones so kind
of on the fly here but
um happy that you're in here and um
i just want to talk mostly i think about
your your story um from van life
to arena life yeah private jet life
yeah i'm rich now yeah filthy rich open
for rogan yeah
i'm uh pretty successful yeah one of the
best in the world
no i don't feel like it's real i feel
like it's all gonna get taken away at a
moment's notice but like at least i
could say i did it you know like i can
retire happy now like what did you used
to do oh i did arenas and private jets
that's crazy i don't think it's gonna
get taken away but that has to feel
crazy that it happened so fast yeah you
know um so
from the first time you went on the kill
tony show yeah what was that kind of
like walking you know you sit in there
you don't know if you're going to go up
or not yeah obviously you've been doing
stand up for a while and have your tight
60 seconds was it a debate which 60
seconds i'm gonna do or did you know if
he calls my name these are my best three
jokes or so yeah i had a good idea i got
called up once and then uh the second
time it was a little bit more of a
struggle but then it's like what you're
feeling in the moment and what you think
your best jokes are kind of different
things so you feel it out do i want to
do stuff that
uh is like my best stuff overall or like
stuff that i can tell really well right
now so i did a little bit of both
um but yeah i mean
i was uh moved to austin um during the
pandemic i mean everything was
topsy-turvy nothing was open things were
like you know weird so i was like let's
just go to austin yeah i don't care if i
get anyone sick there neither do they
yeah it's like where we all agree that
we're gonna tough it out yeah so like
i'm not living with my parents so i'm
only going to get other young healthy
idiots sick that's how i felt in florida
almost the exact same exact same thing
yeah so
doing kill tony being up there for your
for the 60 second um
60 seconds that you have do you think
it's harder to do that because the room
is filled with other hopeful comedians
that want to get up there so they might
be
either more judgmental of your jokes
because they're comedians or not paying
attention because they're nervous that
they're going to go up next
how is that room when you're up there
for that show it's an anton's is mostly
just i mean in vulcan 2 is just mostly
normal people okay so you they're so
normal it's like they're not comedians
at all
so they're a little shy they're a little
unsure of themselves
they're a little like you know
they're you gotta handle them with kid
gloves and then once they trust you then
they'll start bellowing it out like they
have no it's either zero or everything
there's no middle ground with these
uh audience members
so then
you do it the first time you do it the
second time how many times did you just
get pulled randomly before you became
a regular i think twice maybe three
times okay once i did it in la in like
2016 or something oh wow
do you so how long have you been a fan
of this
of the show probably like three years
two years
um
i listened to like a lot of the episodes
back to back you know it was great it's
like a celebration of humanity yeah me
and my friends used in college used to
put that on the tv and just for hours
watching we would not even watch it
weekly so we had more than one to watch
that time
just to binge it does it feel weird
becoming from a fan of the show now
you're a character
obviously you're not a character but a
character on that show yeah
i'm uh
yeah i'm like a recurring character a
cast member
um but yeah it feels awesome you know
it's like it's not even real like
it's like is it the same show i mean
it's changed states
so i don't know it just feels different
but yeah i mean
it's a huge honor like i love it it's
like it shows you people how different
people act and
uh like it's a crash course and what
people are like
and tony's so good at making fun of them
and how to like make fun of them and
yeah how to process people because he
just processes people
so it's like it's a great skill to have
and he knows so much about
every sort of like
culture or any sort of story like he
know he has these jokes about such
specific things i feel like that you
have to be
almost like world educated on to even
think of these jokes like some things go
over my head just because i don't even
get the reference and he seems like he
can
make a joke about any sort of person
about a specific thing
um that's it's almost like an
educational thing in a certain way yeah
i mean everything comes into play when
he's making fun of them every little
part of his life
informs that so you get to see a peek
into his mind
yeah that's great so writing for so
becoming a recurring guest and then
having the 60 seconds to do every week
writing those jokes how does that is
there a difference between writing your
60 seconds for your recurring guest spot
and writing your maybe longer material
or do you think that your style is in
that short punch line anyway so it
doesn't seem to matter i don't really
change it up i do the same thing
um yeah i try to do the same thing i
just
write however i normally write how i did
for open mics i think open mics are
great training
for that kind of format because there's
that pressure to come up with new stuff
people are watching you
uh every week so you don't want to make
your friends listen to the same jokes
over and over right but um yeah i mean
it's similar
uh that but yeah i mean obviously this
is like a real audience
uh they're
not as grumpy
so it's just you gotta account for that
and you know maybe be a more kinder
person than open mics and
yeah not shock them too much right or at
least in the beginning yeah if um
if you're so you're up there and
obviously it's a room that you're
performing in
for a open mic or a regular show it's
just those people you might be filming
it to put on your own platforms but when
you're doing that show kill tony you
know it's these people in this room but
it's also hundreds of other thousands
people
that are i don't know if that sense made
sense hundreds of thousands of other
people that are gonna see it after this
and listen to it you know for weeks to
come yeah um so is is that pressure
different knowing that there's a
way way bigger audience like this
audience that you see with your eyes is
just the tip of the iceberg compared to
you know the comments you could get or
or feedback that you could get online
yeah
it was really nerve-wracking when i
first did it i was out of breath i ran
up on stage
it's funny when the people run up when
they get called out and they sprint up
on stage in the first 10 seconds it's
just
yeah yeah because they're so excited
they don't know what to do
but uh yeah i mean the real audience is
back home uh i mean not the real
audience uh the audience back home is
definitely a consideration
um but i really can't focus on that i
just gotta focus on the audience there
in front of me and if i can make them
laugh hopefully i can make the rest
laugh but they're a good indicator
so do you is how good of an indicator is
kill tony in general being a regular on
that show to try out new 60-second clip
bits of yours you write them down you
get to try them there and then
do you use that as maybe a test run to
see if that's gonna work in your other
shows outside of that or do you test
them in other shows to see if it'll work
on kill tony yeah i do it that way i
don't because kill tony is for a bigger
platform yeah yeah and people are going
to watch it in the future so i want to
make sure it's ready it's your best yeah
sometimes it doesn't always happen but
maybe they'll enjoy the [ __ ] ups yeah
they got to peek behind the curtain
that's something i've noticed from even
going to shows um
last night i went to stand up on the
spot at the festival during this
festival and some of the funniest
moments were when a comedian's up there
trying to make a joke and maybe it
doesn't go over that well flops a little
bit and just there them like
acknowledging that and just being like
all right i'm moving on i guess like
that then that gets the biggest laugh
almost like yeah it's there's a certain
thing of like acknowledging if a joke
doesn't go that well that is almost
funnier than the intent behind that joke
right because if they could just go back
or they go past it then it's like
oh are we
am i feeling it wrong is did i do we not
just see what we just saw yeah but if
they acknowledge it we could be like oh
thank god yeah yeah it is
and it's a looser thing and you can tell
they're more
comfortable and they're not just taken
so seriously and yeah that's good for
comedy yeah
so
come so this this whirlwind of success
that you've kind of been experiencing in
this short amount of time how do you how
does it like i can't even wrap my mind
around how your legs
moved one foot in front of another going
on stage opening for rogue in an arena
like with all those people all those
lights like how did you even
how did you even get up there
that's i mean it might be a stupid
question it's got to be nerve-wracking
yeah i mean it was fine i mean yeah it
was a fun time you know it's more like
you got to do it
like it's a job and uh you don't want to
[ __ ] it up but yeah i mean
um
yeah it was crazy but it was like yeah i
mean it was in the round
so i was standing here in the arena all
around
and he was announcing me
and i started walking up and then he did
the announcement and i was still so far
from the stage
but then i remembered uh rich foss told
me don't run up it makes you look
unprofessional so i was just walking up
and it took forever and eventually i got
up on stage and then they cheered so in
that span from the time he said your
name to the time they could actually see
you or you just thinking
i gotta get up there like but yeah yeah
and people were looking at me walking up
but yeah maybe i should have ran i wish
i ran that could be electric kind of you
just running onto the stage yeah yeah uh
what was better oh you go ahead i was
doing the
kill tony mode yeah exactly i wasn't in
stadium mode but it's hard to get in
stadium mode how is stadium mode like
you have to
do a circle while you're performing
which is something that most people
probably either never experience in
their career or
only do when they're 15 20 years in and
they're like okay i've done a million
shows now i can adjust to having a crowd
all around me how is that
it's different because uh your back is
to the audience
you turn around and there's people
everywhere
i was going from edge to edge just going
all around and then all the other
comedians were in the center just making
a small circle
so that's what i should have done
how was comparing the
walk out to the arena to you getting to
do i saw the walkout of like a ufc
fighter at that ufc event what do you
think would be cooler if you were the
fighter getting announced walking out
like that or if you were the headliner
walking into that arena
um
i don't know i mean
fighting is like so much more visceral
more physical and it's like a different
type of audience different type of
cheering
with the
comedy it's like love and it's like
intellectual respect
um
that's true because half of it i just
realized half the people in the arena if
you were fighting are rooting against
you but everyone in arena for a comedy
bought the ticket to support you so
that's good that is a good point it's
more artistic yeah and it's like you're
conor mcgregor i'm sure that feels
amazing
uh walking in
um but like yeah i mean uh as a comedian
uh
it's different because they're like okay
now time to listen you know it's like
more intellectual more
right brain or left brain or whatever
but like fighting you're just like you
just have to watch it's simpler and then
yeah it's just like more animalistic you
cheer the whole time you can drink the
whole time yeah yeah
that's something i i've noticed but like
doing open mics myself and then going to
like a music concert like a rap concert
and i'll be like man no matter how
good i ever got at comedy i could never
be as cool as what these guys do like
something cool about just like people
putting on a show where other people can
be noisy and like loud at the same time
it just seems more exciting i guess to
me but then it's like
comedy is like you're it's a super power
you're making people involuntarily
yell out you know noises so
um think yeah exactly such a feel
so i also want to talk about the van
life that's another thing uh my
interview prep was a deep instagram
scrub
so
uh you you've lived in a van for what
three three years four years four years
how did that
because now it's kind of a trendy thing
yeah to live in a van you can make a
whole tick tock about it and everyone's
you know
van life was that a
choice of yours to be like this will be
cute on social media or was this like
i'm just living in a van it's just
economically frugal it's like practical
i can move anywhere i don't have to have
a job i can live anywhere i want
uh just to do comedy yeah simplify
everything
uh what do i really need a place for to
sleep uh i can sleep in a car
um but yeah i mean uh like i don't need
to have a nice place to sleep you know
like that's not that important
um
but yeah i mean
um
uh i i think it's uh
it's it's sad that i had to do it but i
think that uh
that's the kind of world we live in so
it's like i'm gonna judge like be like
oh this is the game that we're playing
okay let me
let me uh
put all my eggs in one basket like
ideally we'd be able to house everyone
without making them work a crazy number
of hours because then they could pursue
their passion but
yeah yeah
that's true
is there parts you miss about it or no
yeah i mean i miss not having to commute
just waking up in downtown wherever yeah
um i miss
uh you know
going to mike's and seeing friends
um but yeah i mean overall i wouldn't do
it again unless i had to would you
recommend that to
people who are like i'm all in on comedy
this is all i want to do is stand up
would you recommend that path of just
like this eliminates all the other
[ __ ] from your life you can just
focus on
stand up yeah i don't think it's helpful
to have a job that you hate i don't
think that's good for you
i think you should do what you want to
do and uh you know like torturing
yourself and not sleeping is not good
for you um i think a lot of work is uh
you know like wasted it's just them
trying to extract money from you it's
not good for you it's good for them yeah
that's true but what about the van
specifically do you recommend that
people start
aspiring comics start going with the van
yeah
if you're good at it
yeah don't do it if you're not no shot
yeah yeah but yeah i mean
uh most people can make it there's just
like five or six in a scene that
definitely can't
but if anyone wants to put that work in
then they can make it but that's the
thing it's like most people don't want
to put that kind of
work in or make that kind of sacrifice
right yeah
it's hard too it's a hard thing because
it's not just
you know
the stage time and the shows and hoping
the shows go well and getting your clips
out it's also the the writing process
can be almost the most
daunting in a way because then it's just
you against yourself you know and
there's there's no excuse to to not do
it especially if you have if you're a
full-time comedian or or aspiring to be
and give up your other pursuits of
careers that you don't want and it's
like all right i have to write these
jokes but that can sometimes be the
hardest part because that's when you
really have to face
uh
inward and be like
come out with it you know i feel like a
lot of people
can't get over that that part of sitting
down and writing so for you is that just
like this is my job i'm a professional
or was it ever a struggle for you to
start writing yeah every day
yeah i haven't yeah i should write more
but yeah i mean it's like uh you have to
do something uh and you know like
comedians are so lazy like i don't i
don't do anything today i gotta do
something towards comedy people are you
know in offices and jobs they hate doing
a lot of work for that i should be able
to motivate myself to do work for
something i love
um
i think another thing is like people
don't want to try and fail it's better
to not try and fail than to try and fail
but it's all it's better overall to try
and succeed
than to not try and fail so i just feel
like people don't want to be seen trying
too hard because then if they fail it's
going to look ridiculous
so they uh
they they don't want to like sacrifice
their life yeah they want their life to
be as comfortable as possible yeah and
they can always hold on to the prospect
of i could have done that if i wanted to
but i never tried yeah they can tell
themselves right kind of validate
themselves that way and i feel like
there's a lot of
obviously with social media now it's
helped comedy so much and not even just
comedy all art forms
um with just creative people being able
to show their creativity to
mass people online it's a great thing
but also i feel like a lot of people now
are more
um sheltered with their art or
uh paranoid or self-conscious just from
the people in their life that
they you know they they are
thinking oh these people are going to
judge me for this or talk [ __ ] about
this and it stops them from doing
something
that the youtube comments yeah exactly
yeah so it's that's like where you have
to have a healthy disrespective society
like these people love kim kardashian
why why do i care what they think about
me yeah
exactly and it's like i've
yeah like these aren't even real people
in your life you know
most of these comments most of these
negative comments i feel like i don't
even read the name i just read what the
comment says so at that point it
literally is not even a real person it's
just just the words so let stuff like
that affect you
it's it's kind of sad but it's it's hard
to it's hard to keep yourself
in that perspective of why do i care
about
opinions of people i've never met yeah i
don't know
hateful comments are helpful because
maybe they'll make you motivated to try
harder or show you things that you
didn't know about yourself
like you should use this society around
you to help yourself instead of like you
know keeping it to yourself because if
you put it out there and you hear the
critique you can improve but if you just
keep it to yourself then you're not
hearing that critique and maybe you
could have gotten better if you just put
it out there and you know used the
people and their their attention to
right help you out and there are people
who
really
support and care about
um you and and these people or let's say
anyone gets a negative comment
that they view as negative it could be
coming from a genuine fan who has
followed along the whole time and thinks
actually thinks like hey i think this
might be better this might be an
adjustment
so i guess to
maybe block yourself off from all
criticism and just being an echo chamber
isn't isn't healthy just like taking
everything at its word is is also not
healthy yeah
online is weird it like dave chappelle
said twitter's not a real place like
it's it's weird though because it really
does
feel real like i i deleted my snapchat
for like three days last week just on
accident i need memory on my phone so i
got rid of it and then didn't
re-download it for a few days and it
felt strange yeah like i felt like i was
missing communication with people i felt
like i was walking around and like i
wanted to take pictures of interesting
things i saw and i was like this is
weird snapchat i don't really use
snapchat so
i haven't been on it in a while but i
guess people have different apps that
they use
yeah snapchat for me it came out when i
was a freshman in high school
and so that was
i'm 23 now so that was
seven years ago i think oh that's a long
time but it's just became a way to
communicate with almost like texting
like there's really good friends i have
that i would consider really good
friends that i don't
text them i would just snap them
a lot of snap jamming now too and like
um
i don't know it's just weird it's just
like a
disappearing thing that is attractive
sometimes or just like the 24 hour
disappearing or it just seems faster
which it's not but it seems faster i
think because it does disappear so it's
like
you know that they're you got to look at
it and it's momentary it's like not
recorded forever oh he saw this at this
time it's just like oh i saw it like you
can't be like oh this guy always checks
my messages right away what a loser yeah
yeah or like if you get one back
and let's say like it's someone that you
just wanna wait a few hours to respond
to or you don't respond right away or
maybe you're doing something
like you gotta let it sit there and not
open it because then they know exactly
when you opened it so then it's another
personally i don't like notification
badges anywhere on my phone it drives me
crazy if i even have like a one
next to my text i like to just clear all
those off so
i don't even know why we're talking
about snapchat but um well i think uh
we're talking about like the twitter
isn't a real place and it's like i think
uh the internet is intellectual and
we're used to the physical world but
like thoughts and ideas change
so rapidly like one minute everyone
loved will smith and the next minute
they don't yeah so if you're like on
twitter you're like oh this is
you know will smith is like this and so
like our minds are such malleable things
and then twitter is just a
representation of that of how that
it all kind of shifts and it's kind of
like cool watching everyone's brains
shift together in a way because twitter
seems to be
somewhere where public opinion
is king or it seems to be like it's more
of
like tmz yeah or yeah exactly and it
seems like everyone has the same take i
feel like on twitter yeah i mean our
minds are changing we're like is this
the right answer we're figuring it out
like oh everyone thinks this way so this
must be the right answer but that's not
necessarily always the case i mean it's
some it's most of the times correct it's
kind of cool to observe that as a third
party like pretending to just take
yourself out of it like if you weren't a
human and just take yourself out and
just watch
what humans do on those apps it's super
interesting yeah see how that how that
all works i mean we have a culture we
have a shared consciousness yeah and a
lot of people don't want to admit that
because they abuse it for their profit
but yeah i mean that's where our minds
are at like that's what it looks like
and a lot of people don't like that they
don't want to admit that they just want
it to be the physical world or like oil
or whatever
um but yeah i mean i think that
our minds are or twitter might be a bad
place just because like economically or
socially we're in a bad place i don't
think the concept of people talking to
each other is inherently going to be a
toxic thing right
so it is almost a direct reflection of
where we're at with
right everything it's almost just like
the country vibe check yeah or world i
guess yeah it's something that like you
couldn't even get rid of because it
seems like it's causing some problems
now and has some great aspects too but
if you were like all right let's let's
pretend you're like all right if
twitter's caused too many problems we're
just gonna get rid of it it's too late
now like it's almost necessary to have
some sort of open forum
town square
area where everyone gets to share their
ideas like it's there's no going back
from having an outlet like this yeah
it'd be weird if we did that it'd be
authoritarian it'd be weird like to take
it away and it's like no twitter's not
even a big social media thing it's only
like fourth or fifth
like facebook has way more
instagram has way more it's like but the
idea that it represents is good because
like you go there just to like you know
type out little ideas and then the best
ones hopefully get shared the most yeah
would you say that's your number one app
or social media instagram is yeah why is
that
uh it seems like that's where the most
people are
facebook is kind of dying off slowly
it's more for older people now and it's
like too toxic i think instagram is
newer
like instagram doesn't have all that old
sludge yeah old habits people approach
it differently i've never been
i made a facebook account to find my
freshman year college roommate and then
once i found him because we had to join
this facebook group once i found him i
don't think i ever went back on i don't
really even know how to navigate the
the scene on facebook um it's almost
overproduced there's too many options
you can get too connected but instagram
is sort of like
it's harder to connect with people like
you can't create events or groups or
stuff like that yeah if you have like
group chats of 30 people
but yeah i mean you can't have groups or
pages or stuff so so it's almost like
just like the dumbed-down version of
facebook yeah like simplified
sounds good to me i'd say that has to be
my favorite app yeah this is where like
the more features that are on it the
worse it is like snapchat like yeah
every update it seems like people are
complaining and complete every single
time they update try to make it fancier
everyone is just like giving me
the old one back yeah like we don't want
the most fancy [ __ ] we want like sort of
something that reflects our broken minds
yeah
i think that part of that is that we
just don't like the change like change
of any kind i think it's just like we
don't want to know ourselves that well
we want it to be sort of unknown like
who we are is sort of like
and kind of like this but kind of like
that we don't want to come down
definitively and be like i'm
pro-abortion or something right
and knowing yourself
completely seems like
a good goal to have but also could be
maybe scary for some people as well yeah
i mean we have to have the ability to
change we can't just be like tied to
what we wrote and stuff yeah but that's
funny because i feel like
over the last few years people don't
want to give anyone the opportunity to
change or prove or they don't even want
to
think that there's chances to change
like people getting called out on stuff
they've said
15 years ago 10 years ago for tweets
texts or
even i this is old but like kevin hart
getting removed from whatever hosting
gig that was for a gay joke oscars
and it's like
i don't know comedy when he said that
joke most i was watching seinfeld last
night the episode where uh the writer
thinks that jerry and george are gay and
does the article about him and they keep
saying not that there's anything wrong
with that and i was watching that
episode and i was like there's a lot of
stuff that they would never put on tv i
don't even think it'd get monetized on
youtube in this seinfeld episode that's
a very clean sitcom laugh track sitcom
that's the 80s like those all those
jokes are
are fine and and dandy then so that's
just how comedy has progressed a lot to
what we put on tv or um it's just weird
to think that
everyone wants to say that they can
change and give other people the benefit
of the doubt except for i guess
with jokes like
it seems yeah
i mean i think we're coming from an old
way of doing things where we didn't have
this treasure trove of information on
everyone so whenever something came out
about someone it was like a bigger deal
but now we have everything we're still
adjusting to being like oh
a lot of people
said a lot of crazy [ __ ] back then
because times are different yeah
uh could i get a kleenex
um
i don't have a kleenex okay i i can take
off a piece of paper
um
hopefully some brings you to cleanings
here we go thank you
this is the kleenex break of the podcast
we do this every episode
sponsored by
kleenex isn't that funny uh kleenex
that's a brand there who
took over the name of tissues yeah they
made unbelievable tissues
and now you don't even no one says the
word tissues it's just kleenex for every
brand
although i could not probably name more
than one tissue brand anyway that's kind
of
continental continental i think that's
more toilet paper yeah
they call that toilet tissue bath tissue
there's what is it no one writes toilet
paper on the that says like bath tissue
yeah so i guess it's all tissue
that was my tissue riff while this blew
his nose
um
let's see what i wrote down to talk
about oh
the before
thoughts
oh here we go
how did the kissing thing start
um
well they realized that i'll just tell
them anything they want to hear and then
they started asking me about my love
life and then i was like well you know
like i'm trying to you know
[ __ ] comedians
like because that's who i'm around all
the time and then they're like let's
bring one out
and then they were like is she here and
then they're like yeah she's here and
then like she was sort of like
oh gross he's he's the worst i hate him
and then they're like does anyone want
to kiss him to like kind of balance out
yeah
the fact that she was clearly not
attracted to me
and then uh that girl kissed me and then
like every week tommy was like is it
okay if i do that every week uh some
people are weird about their moms
watching or whatever and i was like yeah
i mean
i don't live my life
in a way that my mom
like she's not like the uh one one
person that i'm trying to impress you
know i kind of need to live my life so
uh but yeah i mean he started doing it
every week and uh it was fun and then
people stopped wanting to kiss me for
whatever reason because they saw the
30 other ones beforehand yeah has your
mom said anything about it or
the career in general no i haven't
really talked to her about it
but uh yeah i mean um i'm sure she she
knows
in general that was that was one of the
best
long-running bits i think they've ever
done
um
so yeah that that and um
is there is there any sort of like
do you do you watch people go up to kill
when you're there and and do you know oh
this is going to be good or this is
going to be bad right away just based on
being around the game for so long
um no i try to be open-minded but
usually you can tell
uh after the first joke how quickly they
get to it
but sometimes people have long jokes
that are good but yeah i mean
it's uh yeah i mean it's tricky it's uh
it's hard to do you know sometimes i'll
think they sucked but everyone else
thinks they did well so it really
depends but do you root for
i you seem like you root for everyone to
do well but i'll ask him do you root for
the uh the person that kills or the
person that has the funniest exit
interview because they didn't do so well
i would rather have them do a funny
interview because then
i don't feel comedically insecure that's
true yeah but that's really not the best
for the show so i try to temper like it
doesn't really matter what i want i what
i want is like [ __ ] up and stupid
uh but i would ideally want for me to be
the funniest person on the show which
doesn't always happen which makes me sad
but you know i try to be the funniest in
the minute and then the interview is
sort of like
a break it's like oh thank god okay i
got that done let's just have fun now
yeah was was that how it was the very
first time going up like oh the
interview's gonna be the break part or
because
for me i would think the most
terrifying part of going up would be all
right i know if this 60 seconds is going
to be good or not i've said it 500 times
in 500 i know if there's going to be
good or not
but
i don't want to get roasted on kill tony
by all these
comedians that i admire and i think that
would be my most nerve-wracking part
would be the the interview after
yeah i mean there's really nothing like
like most people can do about it unless
you come with a prepared story which
they can sniff out right away
that's the best that's the best when
they try to like lie
or be funny in the interview
and
it just gets shut down so fast let us
tell the jokes i love it yeah because i
hate it when people do that in normal
conversation when they just try to take
over and grab as much attention as
possible it should be like half half or
like 20 20 20 20. like uh yeah whenever
people try to do that [ __ ] it's
annoying so it's good that they get
called out and they have to be authentic
and in the moment they can't just go
into their rehearsed stories yeah
who is the
a guest
that has been on the show while you've
been there that you're like wow
this is
something special for me rich foss i
mean
like he was good at it um joe rogan
obviously i've been a huge fan of him
forever
sorry i'm good
um
ron white
i see ron white all the time now sort of
weird
um
kim congdon sarah weinchank
i've watched them uh at the comedy store
so it's like kind of had a crush on them
yeah um
you know jetski johnson she's only been
on the show for a little bit near the
end of their time in l.a but i thought
she was
yeah really really funny she came up
like
almost in a blind spot of me for being a
listener of the show i was listening and
then i feel like i i stopped or you just
got through phases with podcasts i feel
like and then i came back and she was
there so i didn't even know her origin
but i definitely enjoyed her episode she
was a great addition and i loved the la
band too yeah that was the classics the
uh the drum offs
that was some of my favorites terrific
joel berg yeah the jeremiah the
characters yeah the character that that
band is legendary yeah yeah
so you're in austin now
how do you like in texas compared to the
van in new york or just anywhere else
you've lived i love it it's free it's
independent of all the [ __ ] it's
just a community that we created
and we don't have to count out to any
existing power structure it's completely
independent so i love it
as far as the comedy scene in austin
goes obviously there's a festival going
on this week so it's
all over the place what is it like
normally is it like i feel like people
talk about new york la and now
especially since the rogan move austin
as being that third comedy city maybe it
used to be chicago maybe there never was
a true third i feel like austin is
maybe not third place but in that top
three now what is it like just normal
week um
comedy scene here it's amazing i mean
joe rogans flies out mark norman or i
should fear shane gillis they come here
a lot
tom segura lives here tim dillon has a
house here
uh some of the best comedians in the
world are on that joe rogan show
um you know and uh
it's become really really a good place
for comedy and with the rogan club
opening up it'll only get better
so this is like a place where you don't
have to
um
you don't have to uh you know have like
a long track record of uh slumming it in
the clubs everyone's new here
except for like the old scene which is
they're great too
uh but yeah this is like a new thing
it's not like you know
it's not like la or new york where
people who kiss ass the best get ahead
this is just pure meritocracy and it's
attached i feel like from a lot of that
new york and l.a stuff of
trying to get shows or trying to
i don't know
like those two cities the two biggest
cities in the country i just feel like
there's just a different
feeling or different culture in those
cities even outside of the comedy scene
just living there compared to being
in a new place like this and setting up
a new comedy scene where there's not as
many maybe executives or hollywood or
people trying to tell you to be clean or
change or act or stuff like that yeah
that's pretty cool yeah that's the best
part of it
um yeah i mean everyone here is happy to
be here they escaped from wherever they
were
and everyone wants to party and have fun
and people here really nice to each
other
we party all the time we like hanging
out with each other there's less
jealousy
it's a beautiful scene that's awesome
what would you say your favorite room is
around around austin on a week night
um
probably the vulcan just because i'm so
familiar with it the creek has a good
stage i like that setup
um
yeah i mean
the
that's pretty much it a spider house
ballroom i think is wonderful because of
the audience that they get is a little
different from creek or vulcan the more
the old austin okay
is there a you mentioned the old guys in
old austin scene
is there so obviously there's comedy in
every city
to the people that were already here
doing stand up trying to get this scene
off the ground when this flood came in
of refugee comics what was their kind of
reaction like
um the old scene was sort of they just
sort of huddled
uh away and sheltered themselves from
the storm and
sort of uh
you know kept away you know some people
bled through but mostly they just kept
to themselves and
you know they have their own opinions
they're more liberal and the new people
are more conservative but you know i
think uh
i think there was a lot of uh
possibilities for
uh you know cross pollination so i think
i think they're slowly
uh opening up and the new scenes slowly
um ingratiating themselves with the old
scene
that's good to see yeah have you have
you noticed a lot of new brand new
people showing up that move here to
austin
thinking
if i'm here
this is where i'm going to become a
comedian and my problem wasn't that
i'm not writing or that i'm not getting
on stage my problem was i don't live in
austin so if i move here that'll be
solved have you seen a lot of people
that maybe
um aren't doing the work but just want
to be in austin and be around comedy and
be in the scene um around here like i
feel like i guess what i'm trying to say
is i feel like the word austin and
comedy and all this it feels a little
saturated maybe to the outsiders who
love comedy and don't live in austin it
feels like everyone's like blowing a lot
of smoke up austin's ass in a way
just do you feel that is like because
you're around these big names too
um i'm talking more like open mic level
are there a lot of like hangers on
and like weirdos yeah or just the people
that are just flooding in here
just to be around the
austin comedy scene and just kind of
filling it up
um i guess it hasn't reached a critical
mass it's a good number now
i mean it's not really too many weird
people i think it's a
it's a tough city to
come if you want to just
uh
you know clout chase because
it's not that big
so i think that and uh that helps people
not be kind of weird about it
so um yeah i mean i haven't noticed it
too much but i'm sure it'll happen more
and more
uh once rogan's club opens up
um but yeah i mean uh a lot of people
are like looking at austin as like this
new alternative like if they don't want
to go to la or new york
because there's still
obviously great things happening in both
those places so
it is i guess more of an alternative in
that way because i feel like a lot of
i mean if you listen to if you listen to
jre if you if you're just kind of a
casual fan but more in the group that
you are in and these guys it sounds like
la is dead and new york is dead but
there are still great things happening
there in comedy yeah i mean uh we moved
here so we're going to talk [ __ ] but
um it's uh you can't deny like the
history of those cities uh they're great
cities uh it's just like the cost
is uh increasing and the benefits are
decreasing
and we don't need that
old infrastructure comedy is just one
person talking we can do it anywhere we
don't have to they
they're using it to control
like they're using the name of la or new
york to
get more out of people
than they deserve and here like there's
none of that this is just pure this is
100 efficiency yeah
so you mentioned that you all you need
for com you can do it anywhere all you
need is someone talking um you're
running at an open mic
in a park for a little bit yeah um how
was that experience doing comedy in a
park
it was awesome it was gorilla it was
like you know
hodgepodge was crazy
um we had a good time you know uh
as uh i did mushrooms once and we just
started a mic there and
it was a crazy time it was a great
experience um but yeah it was uh
it was
is not the best place for comedy all the
time was it hard to get people to like
focus or like
sit down and and
and watch with you know being in a
public place with other things going on
like what time of day was this at like
six six okay so sun's kind of setting
but there's still other stranger or
pedestrians you know walking around
um i can imagine that that would be kind
of distracting pretty wild the first
show i saw last night stand up on the
spot was in an outdoor
an outdoor covered venues like cedar um
cedar street something yeah some and
that was cool
um there was a lot of
different alternative
shows during the pandemic that i saw saw
mark norman also performing in the park
um
was would you say that open mic that you
put on was the strangest place you've
ever performed in your career
yeah i mean uh it's not ideal but it's
it's got a mystique to it when there is
a pandemic going on and they're like oh
we're all out here yeah that's crazy
so it helped that the pandemic was
happening but ideally you'd want to be
inside yeah like no one would
it'd be hard to get people to go to a
park show now yeah
than then
that's crazy that it because i and i
also that reminds me of
i think i was listening to rogue and to
tell a story about dave chappelle
doing stan he would just
after he left the chapel should just
start doing stand-up in in parks and
just out in public and people would kind
of gather around and listen to them too
so
and obviously that was pretty pandemic
there's something to i feel like
being out out in public and drawing in a
crowd
that has to feel almost like
medieval
yeah it's organic it's like
comedy
in the caveman era yeah
but yeah people want to talk to each
other people want to listen so it's like
you know it's a great thing to do it's
egalitarian it's democratic it's free
anyone can watch anyone who's there
who's uh made the sacrifice of being
there physically in the in that space
that's all you need to do and
i think it's a beautiful thing uh
and i'm sad that uh
it's gone now but you know
uh we can always do it again it's just
like it's not ideal yeah the low
ceilings help yeah
so
there seems to be a different style i
was talking about this in my last
interview of people from new that
perform in new york
seem to have punchier faster
more jokey jokes and people and a life
seem to be more performative and maybe
longer stories or personal
antidotes and
i don't think that was right word but
from austin do you think that this is
developing comedians um
in one way or another do you think that
it's just people are since it's new
they're just coming with what they
already knew and do you think that
there's gonna be an austin style in a
few years yeah i mean every city has a
style it's uh inevitable it's hard for
me to tell right now
uh because it's so new but i would say
that there is like a
like sort of a southern thing going on
here there's like a riffing is like
you know more laid back and sort of like
the southern you know drawl and like
uh
what a sweet tea sipping on a porch kind
of that energy and attitude and
sort of like a cocky
thing like i have a gun so i can do what
i want so i guess it might just play to
the crowd then because that seems super
texas the new york style seems super new
york and the la one seems what i'd
imagine people there
would enjoy too so i i guess that would
just
yeah yeah the audience is your guiding
light so if you can't make them laugh
then you're going to change your act to
make them laugh no matter what it is how
do you figure that out
while it's already happening because
obviously you don't go around and shake
hands with everyone in the audience and
say so what do you like like what are
your interests what
stories would you like just laughs or no
right the faces in the crowd how much
they seem on board with it but in a
packed room how like you can't see even
half the faces i yeah i mean it's such a
i mean when you're up there you have to
be in tune with the audience so
you're gonna feel every little thing
that happens like whoa that was a weird
kind of laugh that corner was a little
weird and then that's going to work into
your head subconsciously you don't even
have to think about it yeah and the next
time you you're like maybe i shouldn't
do that joke that got that weird
response maybe i should do this joke
that got the better response
and then slowly
your style changes for the audience
isn't that kind of a
a dangerous game maybe to play because
every audience is so different so what
if that
that one joke that you might have
changed
uh would have killed
in a whole different audience or a whole
different city like how do you even
determine
i don't know like is it weird to be like
is is this audience worth me changing
for how do you not get defensive and be
like
no it was them because i know that this
killed two nights ago well that's where
your personal tastes and intuition and
your uh you know your
uh desires come in where you're like oh
i like that joke i think there's
something there it's like feeling it out
it's not always conscious it's more like
your at your emotions towards that joke
uh and uh you know and then you've
you figure it out however using a
combination of uh subconscious and
conscious be like that one got this many
laughs i'm gonna stop doing it yeah
that's that's so impressive and i guess
that's what kind of makes a professional
a professional because like i feel like
it's so much
easier or not easier but just so much
more um
it makes more sense if you're nervous or
if you're not experienced to be like i
got this type 5 i'm going up i'm saying
these words exactly how it happens and i
just hope that this audience likes it
you know like no matter what show i'm
doing these these are the sentences i'm
saying this is my five minutes and
i have other jokes but i'm not i'm not
prepared or i'm gonna get too flustered
to
swap things out or know
those pockets of problems in the
audience yeah i mean uh
i
am pretty scripted i say the jokes the
same way but i choose which jokes to
tell when and how to say it so that's
where my
audibles come in
but everyone's different and if you
don't feel good telling a joke then you
shouldn't be saying it you should be
excited to tell that joke and if you're
not it probably means you're not you
shouldn't be you should be telling
another joke yeah
that makes that makes sense it's very
obvious would you say that there's jokes
that
you're tired of telling at this point in
your career yeah that you know work and
all of them
i hate i wish i could just have a new
act yeah uh but yeah i mean i feel like
whenever i'm hacky or stupid or dumb or
whatever
um but yeah i mean that's like the
negative voice it's like you know these
jokes work they they're fine they're not
terrible yeah all the time but yeah i
mean uh
i just uh
i uh
i i try to write i try to use that
hatred of my own jokes to write more new
jokes
and uh hopefully i write uh
hopefully i can use that um but yeah i
mean
yeah i
i get sick of my jokes and if i'm not
excited
to tell it then the audience could tell
so i try not to do jokes that i don't
like right
one last question for hans kim i just
want to throw this out and then you can
plug some dates or socials and all that
if you had any advice to give a comedian
that was in your shoes three years ago
what would it be
uh
i would say
um
you got to love the audience
uh it's got to be coming from a place of
love and
you got to work hard at it
so both it's kind of hard because if you
love it then people are like oh i just
have good emotions and feelings i don't
need to work hard uh but if you work
hard you're like man i work so hard on
this joke they don't like it [ __ ] them
yeah so it's like you gotta balance it
out i would say i mean that's what i
would say because i'm uh autistic
but yeah that's what i would say okay
awesome well thank you hans kim do you
have any dates or socials that you want
to throw out for the youtube uh dj hans
kim i uh go to chicago and go to detroit
and go into
different places
i don't know when or how but
it's gonna happen all right so if you
live in any different places
some time he might be there but thank
you for coming in and thanks for having
us time yeah it was fun thank you man
[Music]
you